[Music]
all right so there's an game exclam
every Tuesday from 7:30 to 8:30 here at
the st. Louis trance club and today
we're going to be talking about rook and
Bishop versus rook and Knight and games
practical end games a very very
important imbalance and hopefully we're
going to get to learn some new things
what do we know about it first things
first
which one is usually better which
cooperation is usually better
rokka rokka bishop or rook and Knight
rook and Bishop rook and Bishop as I
mean the theory says rook and Bishop
most of the times is going to be rook
and Bishop but obviously there's going
to be exceptions as well
and we're going to see some of those in
today's class I did have rook and Bishop
very very broken Bishop versus rook and
Knight or I did face rook and Bishop and
I had rook and Knight and I felt you
know the differences and how powerful
this cooperation can be Queen and Knight
is better than Queen and Bishop
generally they complement each other
better but Luke and Bishop are working
very very well together generally again
this is the rule there's always
exceptions and today actually we're
going to be starting with the exception
we have this position and you're going
to be white and you're going to try to
explain to me the position and
potentially give me the best candidate
so take your time think a little bit of
about what you might need to do and and
let me know
why to move white to move I think in all
of them it'll be white to move if I'm
not mistaken yes we're going to have
white in all the examples we're going to
look at today this is a game between
Java and meat on camel grandmaster from
Poland I think Jo bhava everybody should
know about you Bob is quite famous
entertaining player right in this
particular case you meet or in general
it also depends on the structure that's
I guess another important factor
whenever we're assessing this type of
imbalances if we have pawns on both
sides of the boards obviously the bishop
is going to be the better piece because
it has a long-range action and it's
going to be easier to like transfer it
from one side to the other whereas the
knight is just kind of stagnant if we
have closed positions of course the
knight is probably going to be better
and so on open centered we know the
bishop should be better but in this
particular case what
how would you how would you assess the
position what do we need to do as well
ye sure Black has more space but that
would also be a liability
aha very interesting so we spot some
weaknesses on the dark squares of blacks
right in blacks camp also as as Ken was
what was mentioning the pawns on the
queenside are a little bit overextended
I would say and they could potentially
become targets also whose King is closer
to the center White's King is closer to
the center right and he has a lot of
ways of penetrating blacks position so
that could potentially become a factor
as well so we spot all these ideas
candidate moves candidate moves yes
absolutely that is that is the answer
Bishop takes c6 is the first move and in
this particular case as I was mentioning
we see the exception we are going to
give our Bishop which is a good Bishop
could potentially attack the pawns on
the Queen side but we are going to give
it for tonight because the knight in
this particular case is a very good
defender and it defends the dark squares
the entry points the d4 square the B 4
square for the King potentially a5 and
and so on so Bishop takes c6 is the
first move now if black takes with the
rook the situation is going to be quite
quite bad quite fast what are we going
to do
what if you go route d3 I think I'm
going to go King g7 maybe even rook c7
could be an idea
rook c7 put my bishop on the long
diagonal on c6 if I manage to coordinate
my pieces then my position is not going
to be that bad
let's let's try to calculate a little
bit further that looks like a good move
that absolutely looks like a good move
and it's probably as good as the main
continuation though you're going to take
with the king right and now I'm going to
try to stop you from coming with a king
to be four yes and now I would go here I
have to go here if I take on before then
just simply take with the king and then
the be five points hanging so I have to
pull I have to play four oh I think it's
I think it's still winning I think it's
still winning
correct correct you can just move the
night away then free up this square King
before King c5 if you manage to get your
king to c5 position looks really bad
yeah so I think 94 is a pretty good move
as well also rook takes c6 directly just
exchange and we also see the fact that
the knight is not on d4 so the King has
two ways of penetrating blacks position
before in d4 and black is just simply
not going to be able to stop that
so after this King c3a five King before
the position is completely losing we're
going to take one of the we're going to
take one point we see central central
King in the endgame is an extremely
extremely powerful factor so the
position is just losing he takes with
the bishop what to do what to do
like d4c this night before
94 is an idea but hmm that's another
idea that's another very good idea but
we also have to pay close attention to
our opponents ideas and threats we will
we will see in just a second but I think
yeah black has a little trick that might
actually equalize on the spot and that
is route d8 getting off the pin on the C
file now pinning the night.the the pawn
on g2 is hanging so after rook c6 rook
takes d4 this position is not that easy
I'm going to play okay for next move I
think the fact that my rook is active is
is going to allow me to equalize I think
this is just an equal n game so we'll be
very careful not to fall under this type
of tactical challenges if you go King
III Bishop takes g2 and black is
perfectly fine so J Bhabha spotted this
and play much more naturally move again
he's on a very unpleasant pin we know
that if he tries to play something like
Bishop d7 he's going to have problems in
the ensuing gang game in the ensuing a
king a knight versus King and bishop
hanging because the King just enters the
position via d4 c5 really quickly and
then the pawns are just folded so first
things first King III of course let's
not allow him to go room d8 and get off
the pin right makes a lot of sense King
III King g7 what now
d4 or even better you had you had that
idea right but the problem is now my
king is also closer to the bishop and
after our night before I can just simply
go King this Evan exactly exactly
and we can also I the dark squares
that's the problem right now the King
defense we don't do we want to exchange
all the pieces and enter the King's
endgame probably not probably not that's
just going to be a draw so Knight to g5
of course very good move h6 mmm-hmm
Knight to e4
let's say rook to c7 again it's very
difficult for him to get off the pill
what now how to continue
Knight to c5 okay but that also allows
me to get off the pin yes
Bishop takes g2 could be actually I
think this I don't know if I want to
give you the a6 pawn it's a good
question
I could I could go Bishop g2 and I think
this already complicates matters more
than we should
Knight x86 you're still better I think
but I think I'm going to take this guy
take and then just try to enter with the
king we should be five here
I don't like night before just coming
with tempo and then the problem is King
comes to c5 so I think I would try to
stop you from coming to c5 with this
move always I'm going to try to stop you
from activating your king it's extremely
important if you manage to activate your
king
why White's position is just going to be
winning so always I'm going to try to
stop you
I think your work or complicating
matters too much we don't need to do
that he's not threatening anything was
the idea with 96
again 96 allows black I think to do
something that would help his cause
[Music]
which doesn't kill you by any means
you're still perfectly fine i think
after f6 you can go something like king
de for this still looks very good
you have you have great control over the
dark squares great control but probably
i don't have to play that i can just
move my king maybe d8 now you have night
of 7 that's a good idea I guess I'd have
7 Luke takes of 7 will take c6 and
you're winning a pawn and your rook is
active that's winning
that's definitely winning what in what
moment after King d8 here after King the
8
yakkung da losers
maybe f5 alright let's try five
I mean look 96 is it's not really doing
that much yeah yeah it's one of those
good-looking pieces that's not really
doing much you can of course you can go
Lea or dress for the festivities but
I mean do you need all these things like
again if I exchange that the night for
the bishop the bishop for tonight then
my chances of surviving are you know
getting higher and higher
well now if you go King before I go rob
d7 so here mm-hmm
but now I'm not going to let it do that
I'm going to go King to d7 I have seven
and then we were starting to get
unnecessary complications yeah very
unnecessary we don't need those all
these things were not even a hurry guys
he doesn't have any threats there is
absolute almost paralysed King D seven
is met with ninety five check and that's
a double threat he cannot move his
bishop
rook d3 allows the exchange bishop takes
e4 I mean the rook on the C file is
really nicely placed g4 is an
interesting move but I want you to tell
me the idea behind it potentially that
square f4 could be utilized as an entry
square for my king
if the h6 pawn moves then King a4 King
g5 mean maybe in an endgame later on
could be useful so as long as it doesn't
attack the pawn on e5 we don't have to
go up f4 that's that's that's one way
and another idea behind you for is what
do we do with weaknesses with pawn
weaknesses we fix them right so g4 h4 h5
could potentially become very unpleasant
for a black because after that after the
exchange Knight f6 98 is a big threat
and the pawn on h6 is immobile yeah so
again we're not in a hurry we're really
not in a hurry so g4 was played by Joe
baba King to d8 what did you know what
is he threatening what is black
threatening what is black threatening
Bishop takes c4 so let's run away with
the night
wer were eyeing that age six weakness if
you go on this is a yo king e7 oh yeah
my knight on d6 is a beautiful piece
it's not really doing much though it is
a beautiful piece but it's not attacking
any weaknesses try to attach some
purpose to your pieces what now continue
with your your plan fix the weakness
first h4 of course h4 king c8 black
simply doesn't have what to play
h5 is is an option any other option Nige
eh yeah and that's why he played h5
taketake we go back I mean does he have
anything to do he doesn't have anything
to do he's completely lost and and we
don't have to hurry
that's the point 1965 B for Roxy want
room d7 night of 6 H 5 the pawn March is
all the way to age 7 the room g1 room g8
and the game is over I think they I
think he played a few more moves and he
resigned pretty easy pretty easy and a
very controlled conversion yeah I mean
he didn't allow his opponent any sort of
counter play ok let's do another one
with when the night is better than the
bishop yeah yeah he's his kind of stock
also and once again we see the
difference between the activity of
White's pieces of all of whites pieces
and the passive black pieces having the
active pieces in the end game yeah
you cannot move rook c8 because of rugby
7 and then the b61 is unprotected and
cannot be protected so kind of his
pieces are to be honest almost in
Seussville now the knight to be honest
is quite nicely placed on c4 we could
potentially find an even better square
and that could be where D 5 D 5 the
central central square and you're also
allowing the king to go to c4 I mean
that could be an idea for the future but
once again we're not in a hurry
generally in this type of dominant end
games we have to search for new
weaknesses like we did in the previous
example when we blocked with g4 h 5 ur
just spotted that weakness on h6 what
could we do to improve our position in
this case
the rook is predominant to be honest at
least for the moment she's doing fine
G for of course G for creating some more
weaknesses opening up a new front adding
some more tension to the position yeah
always do that
we're not in a hurry HD HD Bishop h4 f3
f-five strength is best to get some sort
of counterplay how to continue there's
plenty of ways to be honest by this
moment to that wind but let's try to be
precise
yes we can do that Roxy 7 is also move
I'm a bit worried about this move down
I still think white should be winning
but I feel like I'm allowing some
counter play now if you take I'm going
to get my rook active with Luca fade
rock afraid Bishop d8 goes back to
defend the b6 pawn and then the the
could potentially start creating some
problems
mm-hmm and now let's say gonna go here
I agree I agree once again unnecessary
counterplay I just don't want to allow
him any sort of complaint at all if
possible I mean sometimes you have to
accept some comfortably but in this
particular particular case there's
absolutely no need to do that yeah
proxy seven is also is also a good move
oh yes the knight is too noisy for sir
so rooks e7 indeed is a useful move
you're attacking you're preparing to
attack on the sixth rank with Ruby six
through b6 rook takes g6 a lot of
weaknesses and probably this is a good
enough winning move he chose to play GTA
5 GTA 5 because he spotted another idea
and there is to pacify his species
pacifies black species and now just
improve them all together prove all of
whites pieces after killing the whole
counterplay so what to do how to
continue how to do that
now 93 now we can go 93 the rookies
passive on b8 the rule doesn't have time
to get into the fray ever 95 look to b7
what now
none of black's pieces yes yes we're
keeping them extremely restricted yeah
so we're gonna go King c-4 first say
King d6 which this pawn the pawn c4 yeah
yeah we want to keep the king keep the
King active and keep its options
available open because if we go see 4th
then closing the position a bit too much
you have to be careful in this type of
closed structures if you close it too
much then you're just simply not going
to have any entry squares after that
yeah again I'm I'm pretty sure there's
more than one ways of winning this
position but I would definitely not go
for that one that looks way way too
dangerous I mean I think about it this
way whenever you get to g2 or to h3 I'm
gonna start checking you and then I'm
going to plant the rook on g3 if you go
if you go up too much right now is a
black we played King to d6 after king c4
rook to a8 okay that's an interesting
idea
hmm okay I'll go King D seven that's
what he played in the game it's a good
move Roque it is a good move
what now no that's not gonna work
you're trying to lose this position
somehow that's a that would actually
yeah I mean you might lose this position
I mean I can go rock up seven if I
really want to and force you to go back
basically but no no no no I'm not gonna
I'm gonna go after your f3 pawn I'm
going after your f3 pawn nobody I mean
this is something you should never do in
your chest life correct correct
now it's time to redirect the rook
because because we have more space on
the Kings side to attack it to attack
blacks position so he went rook to a-1
King to e6 Rock h1 exactly rook to b8
rook h7
well he's kind of in suits one more or
less what can he do
actually it's a good question
he played Bishop g5 now Rock age 5
Bishop d8 and now let's let's get our
night out somehow it's time to get the
night out how do we get the night out
and then King III c4 no but then once
again your King doesn't enter the game
no yeah you could if you would play
someone like rook c8 or something like
that but he's not gonna know how to get
the night out
good good start now what can black do
we have a big threat and that is d7 yes
why
no he's not losing a piece exactly he's
losing the pawn on d6 were threatening
to go Knight xb6 simple as that yeah so
king de 7 is the only move now Knight
xv6 rook takes P 6 and we just win a
piece but now a different opening is on
the board and there is Knight of 6 9 12
6 the bishop is still pinned came to e6
where do we put the knight Knight g4 of
course Bishop to c7
uh-huh exactly King to d7 hmm which is
completely winning for sure he played
the move rook to age seven first yeah
but this is still I mean it's completely
hopeless I guess he can he can he kind
of has to anyway but down upon this is
just completely winning again he is
completely uh passive and that's a big
big problem look at five we take another
pawn and everything falls everything
just simply forms now we go c4 well he
did play until the end
actually you know what tantor is that
you play you play I'm curious if you can
beat me this hanging no come on come on
you tell me you play ah
kz6 okay already [ __ ] already a bit
suspicious okay let's go c4 b7 rugby one
I think I think we just made the draw I
think we just made a draw I'm going to
sacrifice my rock then I'm gonna go see
3 c2 and then I'll give you another I'll
give you another strike
come on I mean
correct correct he's still winning he's
still winning
mr. winnings hmm it's whites turn
we tried king c6 and we tried the rook
c6 I don't think then rugby one okay
where it's very I mean it's very
important I think if you go on c6 I go
c4 I think this is a drop you know I
mean it's just the king is very far
the king is just very far
and I'm gonna go here we exchange that's
a drum so that's the problem this design
games are quite tricky but I think King
Asics is uh is still winning should be
winning Oh actually is it winning let's
see is this winning King do one here
generally we like to keep the rook
behind the pawn still c3 the king is
very far the king is very very far I
mean whatever you want to put the rook
let's say on each one and the two and
now you have to start giving checks then
it's going to be a draw
yes if you don't go roughly one you gain
one tempo so how do you how do you get
into Luke versus night how do you do
that
I don't think you can I think you just
simply cannot stop my pawn from
promoting thanking c6 c3 King here see -
look here King D 3 and I'm right in time
right in time I really even if you can't
go location - I go King D 1 King c3i I
pipe I promote a queen
yeah so you have to be a little bit
careful let's try some other move
I mean you really close the promotion
you have to understand that you really
really close the promotion D - of course
- D - now what do you threatening to go
Ruby - b7 and that's it game is over
right so you you build the bridge and
that's King to e5 was played came to c6
now it's safe to go there
c4 b7 push the pot now Chuck and now
this is the bridge
we made the bridge and this is just game
over
well it's a sip on yeah so it there's
still some dangers lurking the the the
King is way too far the king is only
four I'm quite curious actually
is it yeah this should be winning this
should still be winning if the King if
the White King would be somewhere on h7
or somewhere something like that even on
that five I think this is this is a draw
if I if I was probably at all ready but
yeah this is this should be winning yeah
we start checking
the stairs now we just go here and
that's it then I will run away with my
king and I mean I will just beat you
with Queen vs. night it's fun
well it's funny I think there was a
title Tuesday which was today actually
but many many months ago I saw a queen
versus night at GM versus like some
2,200 and then GM couldn't win with a
queen which is ridiculous huh yeah they
played they played forever at at some
point it was just like 50 move draw but
you have to tell me the idea hmm so
we're working along along the lines of
trying to exploit the weaknesses of
course B 394 Peter is the move of course
94 just bishop things before
well not only I think you lose mum like
at least I think you lose both pawns I
think a for I have a few ways of
actually know just one way it should be
yeah no it should be winning because the
rookies in front of the pot the black
role coops the black rook is in front of
the pawns so even this should be winning
with rugby 3 we have side control and
then we go King the three kings III King
b2 we defend upon on a3 and then our
rook is going to be able to start
supporting the pawn supporting the
movement of the pony if this truck would
be on a one that's a completely
different story if the rook is behind
the pond then blacks chances of making a
drawer quite substantial but I think in
this position we can do something even
better than that of course this is game
over next move
next next move is what I don't think
Ruby ate I think next move is even
better in that rock a5 take another pawn
yeah the pawn on e4 is going to be
defenseless then we're going to have
connected pastures and we know that
that's just easy with so instead of 94
you played the move rook to e5
continue
thank you thank you thank you finally I
was waiting for blunders thank you thank
you that was my only chance that was my
only chance
right before I mean again I'm facin as
much as possible look for what your
opponent is trying to do as well of
course follow your plan but also look
about you know threats in the position
King the tree simple as that but this is
the difference between you know winning
a game and just completely spoiling this
type of advantage I'm waiting
g-iii very good good job
now counter player he was trying to play
a four he was trying to displace this
bishop from e3 from its perfect position
only three does just simply controlling
the knight on his six he was trying to
play a four game counter play of course
we're not gonna allow that g3 King to
have so continued Rock a six of course
before I mean probably the better
defense would have been a four but still
this is very very close to being just
hopeless after because he can play the
move Knight to c5 and at least force the
exchange of the minor pieces
this is annoying exactly this is
annoying I'm I'm I'm pretty sure it's
still winning but it's not as easy yeah
I think Brookes something like group c4
keep the rukon on the fourth-ranked then
play for how how does he get behind part
I don't think he has a way to do that
actually
rook d5 okay let's go
d4 huh
I think I'm gonna let you do that I
think I'm gonna let you go behind the
pawn actually no I don't want I want to
be precise I'm not gonna let you do it
actually give me one one moment
game over
I'm getting all your pants ya know so
it's still winning but probably a
slightly better chance if you play the
move before and I think Yusupov played a
little bit of an inaccuracy here he
played a move a taste before which I
don't necessarily recommend I think a
four would have been much better okay
calculate the rooks III yeah but what he
was saying was after 95 king before
directly that's what you were saying
right exactly so after 95 King before
calculate that or you go root k7 and you
win on the spot
okay seven Chuck in intermediately
remove intermediary track that picks up
well I mean you have rookie seven you do
have rookie seven but now this this end
game is just simply winning because our
King is very close to the pause yeah so
this is what he missed this is what you
soup of missed and he just to come
before this is winning this is still
winning but it's not as easy a for to
keep more pieces more pawns on the board
more weaknesses on the board is is much
better yeah
Roxy for now we're transferring the to
Roxy six-story we're transferring the
route to c4 in this position Bishop d2
95
I mean really you're allowing me to get
so much activity for absolutely no
reason once again why I'm not even sure
if I'm gonna take that pawn I think I'm
gonna play 94 first okay I take your
pawn so and you think this is winning
that's a big maybe yes ma correct i it
might be winning but actually I don't
think so after Luke f3 you might think
even be worse slightly worse I mean
you're going to make a draw of course
but I think you have to suffer a little
bit so no come on I mean again you're
you're making moves that you absolutely
don't need so Roxy six keep control over
the position King C for Ricky for King
de 5 King F 6
Roxy for rook takes e4 King takes e4 the
bishop still protects everything on e3
mm-hmm which is probably better but then
I still go king c6 I'm still going to
take that pawn I mean you can go rookie
four but I think I can just simply take
now take take like collect this pawn
king c4 b4 b5 b6 push the pawn wait so
can you occupy this perfectly fine but
it's still winning it doesn't help that
much and now he plays King takes before
which is probably a little bit worse
because it allows certain things it
allows an unnecessary simplification and
there is the f4 move I think we should
Bishop d2 was much better and now if f4
Bishop takes before and the king is
closer to the King side take take now we
put the bishop on f4 we defend the pawn
on G 3 B 4 B 5 and is winning so after
King takes before you're allowing some
complications after f4 take take let's
see how he converted
what to do kinky for was probably better
he played a movie night to a show I
think kinky for was much better
exactly now you're threatening things
such as jittery not yet jittery because
g3 I can just simply take take on g3 and
then when you take the bishop I take
your knight on f4 so Bishop I mean you
can play Bishop before and this is not
easy to convert yeah pretty sure it's
still winning or you go Bishop here I
think you have to go g3 button I take
and I put my King to d5 really quickly
yeah to shoulder your king to keep it
away and they are yeah that's true I did
they absolutely 100% nobody's
disagreeing I'm trying to figure out
whether this is still winning or not I
don't have table base and any any we're
we're not cheating here that's just
cheating so night to be eight yeah the
problem is if you go King to be seven
what do I do
mmm King d3 that's the problem
how is this still winning I think I see
what how
let's see if you go Bishop e5 9797 sorry
no sorry
if you go here actually I just go King
c4 and I think this is just simply draw
I think actually this position is a draw
so if you go here I have to go 97 King
c6 now I just simply go back yeah
yeah there's no way you can make
progress game over
draw so he could have at least put up a
much better fight than what he did in
the game by just simply following common
practices and there is of centralizing
the King in the position centralizing
the King and trying to exchange his last
pawn as soon as possible he played the
move Knight h5 with the same idea the
problem is that right now the bishop the
King is a little bit far and I'm not
really sure if you managed to actually
exchange the last point because of what
well if you do that I think you might
have some problems if you go before I go
he's gonna go g3 once again he's going
to exchange his last point
you saw he saw it it something so he did
when I played before and it showed the
new new variation over here inside
yeah Bishop I said one of course Fisher
pay seven with the idea to go Bishop ei
put the bishop on g3 and avoid the
exchange of the last part if we manage
to do that then we're probably going to
it and that's what happened and now it's
just easy conversion he has an exchange
the last part we're just simply going to
push it use it as a bait then get the
Jeep on and beat two points up
centralizing take the Jeep on
it's cold yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's there's absolutely I mean there
there are plenty of other ways I think
to wind its this game but it's a good
technique I think he had a good
technique and he resigned because the
knight is trapped I think you go here
and now I go what to swim on the spot be
six it's all fun now it doesn't go
anywhere you have to keep up tonight
game over so nice conversion by a mr.
Yusupov I think I think Yusupov was
playing and Anand was black quite a
classic hmm he can move the other porn
but then I'm gonna take it for sure and
now once again you have to move the
knight you're not escaping you're not is
the knight the knight moves the knight
gets gets lost for sure all right so
that's it always always pay close
attention to this end games of route
Bishop versus rook and Knight there
they're going to arrive very often in
your games I'm pretty sure and you're
going to apply all this type of ideas
and concepts to maximize your your
chances of winning
[Music]